Thomas Edison is one of the most famous
inventors in history he had over a
thousand patents and countless
inventions many of his inventions
changed the world
how different would our world look if he
never existed would we still be living
in the dark would we be listening to the
radio and without Edison's brand of
industrial light magic would we still
have Star Wars this is what if and
here's what would happen if Thomas
Edison was never born yeah we know
Thomas Edison wasn't the sole inventor
of the light bulb some people say he
stole it from other inventors like
Nikola Tesla or Joseph Swan many of
Thomas Edison's biggest breakthroughs
were creations that other inventors may
have been striving towards around the
same time multiple discovery is a
hypothesis that most scientific
discoveries and inventions like the
lightbulb are made independently and
around the same timeframe by multiple
scientists and inventors that is to say
if it worked for Edison many of his
inventions probably would have been
invented anyway but what if they weren't
remember when we said Edison owned over
a thousand patents yeah this guy kept
busy inventing tons of different things
some incredibly useful and others not so
much
Edison even invented a version of the
telephone we're most familiar with
Edison as the inventor of the light
bulbs we use today now what if we didn't
have those well without them we'd
probably be hundreds if not thousands of
years behind compared to where we are
today they allowed us to see at night
easily compared to all the technology we
have now that may not sound all that
special but it's one of the most
important inventions of all time having
a convenient light source changed
people's lives gone were the days of not
being able to go out at night this
vastly changed every industry
restaurants cafes even offices with a
convenient light source people were able
to work longer which led to even more
technological innovation it's safe to
say that without lightbulbs we wouldn't
have our smart phones 4k
TVs even our cars the phonograph was
another Edison invention it allowed
people to record their voices and play
them back for the first time eventually
this was used to record and playback
music over time a smaller version was
invented and soldiers took the
phonograph to war almost like an
old-school boombox without this
invention we wouldn't hear much music on
the radio there would have been no
record players Walkmans or eventually
ipods would Michael Jackson as we knew
him have even existed
Thomas Edison invented the alkaline
battery throughout our history alkaline
batteries have been in nearly every
wireless device from flashlights to Xbox
controllers to computer mice the world
would look vastly different without
these devices in our life now as we said
Edison is considered the father of a lot
of these things but taking multiple
discovery into consideration it's safe
to say they would have been invented
anyway and the world would look pretty
similar to how it does today but one
thing that would look completely
different without Edison is Hollywood
Edison's lab invented one of the very
first movie cameras and in 1893 Edison
invented the very first movie production
studio known as the black mariah short
films were made here featuring
vaudeville performances magic tricks
even the world's first cat video with
several patents involving filmmaking
Edison would sue any other filmmaker he
saw as a threat other film studios
created camera technology of their own
to avoid being sued so Edison decided to
join forces with them and established a
motion picture patents company
filmmakers had to pay the company to
make films and even then they were
saddled with tons of restrictions so
sick of Edison's rules the artists
packed up and moved to a little
agricultural town known as Hollywood a
perfect spot for rogue filmmakers the
land was cheap the weather was great and
most importantly California lawyers
didn't take Edison's patents as
seriously as they did on the East Coast
Hollywood was born feature films were
made then television shows what if
Hollywood never existed
no Citizen Kane no Star Wars no avatar
the television would still be invented
but when there have been any good shows
to watch if it weren't for Thomas Edison
would you even have been able to watch
what if
[Music]
you